Disney has given us some iconic
characters over the years but not all of
them translate while in other cultures
sometimes these changes are barely
noticeable but other times they're huge
we've got 10 Disney characters that were
changed in other countries lined up for
you so stick around to find out which
Disney Princess goes by a completely
different name in other parts of the
world doesn't give you power to create
life it's a home utopia news anchor in
2016 Disney released Zootopia and it
quickly became a fan favorite thanks to
the adorable animal kingdom this world
looked a lot like ours except instead of
people everyone was an animal it was
hilarious to see normal everyday tasks
carried out by various creatures one of
the funniest things was the news scene
one news anchor was a snow leopard but
the other one depended on which country
you were in in America and Canada the
anchor was a moose however moose aren't
common everywhere else so China had a
panda Brazil featured a Jaguar and the
land down under had a koala either way
they were all pretty adorable girl plane
Disney Pixar's Cars franchise was a huge
hit in 2013 they decided to make a
spin-off called planes it's all about a
small town plane who wants to be a racer
it's adorable and totally underrated but
one character in the movie is completely
different outside of the USA Rochelle is
one of the planes she's pink and hails
from Canada but Rochelle is a totally
North American name in Russia they
changed her name to Tanya she was
Carolina and Brazil and German kids know
her as Heidi we aren't sure why they
changed her name and no one else's which
name do you like best for this girl
plain sugar rush racer wreck-it Ralph is
such an amazing movie there are so many
pop-culture references that it's hard to
keep up one of these references is in
the name of a racer from the game sugar
rush minty Zaki is named after a famous
Japanese animator named Hayao Miyazaki
he is famous for awesome movies like
spirited away in my neighbor totoro
minty Zaki was a way for the animators
to pay tribute to one of their icons but
minty is totally different in Japan
maybe they thought it would be weird
since Miyazaki is still alive in their
country she looks totally different and
her name is minty Sakura she also
doesn't seem to represent mint candies
anymore hockey players one of the Disney
movie
with the most changes in the other
countries is inside out there was a lot
that just didn't translate in the USA in
Canada Riley's dad watches hockey in his
brain but hockey isn't a big deal
outside of those countries the most
popular sport in the world is soccer or
football Americans call it soccer but no
one else does so they changed the team
to be a whole new sport they made it a
lot better for other countries dr. Wu
since Disney bought the Marvel Cinematic
Universe we can include a character from
Iron Man 3 dr. Wu is a Chinese doctor
and scientist and he's an old friend of
Tony Stark in most of the world he only
appears in a very tiny part of the movie
but in China it was much more prominent
there are several more scenes with dr.
Wu they even introduced his nurse
however she can only be found in the
Chinese version of the movie in China
this film is four minutes longer than
other versions these additional scenes
are spread throughout the film and
center around dr. Wu and his nurse an
American Hero
Buzz Lightyear is one of the best Disney
Pixar characters of all time he was
introduced as a new toy in the first Toy
Story movie woody was jealous but the
end up being friends
buzz is supposed to be an American hero
he is named after the American astronaut
Buzz Aldrin who is one of the first
people on the moon and the animated buzz
gives a motivational speech in front of
an American flag but that wouldn't mean
as much to other countries outside of
the USA Fuzz stands in front of a globe
and the song one world anthem plays in
the background
love to see you try the foo Gaston
sidekick in Beauty and the Beast is
totally obsessed with him the foo is
guest Ron's biggest fan in both the
animated and live-action versions in
2017 Disney released the classic films
live-action remake and they turned his
obsession into a bit of unrequited love
it's really subtle but near the end the
food dances with another man they got a
lot of criticism for this but that scene
was totally cut from the film in Kuwait
being a part of the LGBTQ community is
against the law there so Disney had to
play down the Fu's feelings in order for
their movie to be shown in Kuwait
Riley's food okay this next change is
super subtle and asked nothing to do
with characters and everything to do
with food
an inside out a young Riley is shown
eating in her high chair
her parents are trying to feed her
broccoli but she's just not having it
broccoli is not a popular veggie for
most kids in the world but that's not
true at all in Japan kids love broccoli
there that scene did not translate well
so animators had to change the vegetable
so what veggie do kids hate in Japan
this may shock you but it's green
peppers Randle's cupcakes we've got
another food change for this next Disney
character in Monster University Randall
Boggs desperately wants friends he makes
Mike some cupcakes they spell out be my
pal in English and are soon altered to
spell out lame when the cupcakes get
shoved onto Randall but the words pal
and lame just don't translate well in
other languages most languages would
need a lot more cupcakes for the first
sentence so in other countries Randall's
cupcakes just have smiley faces on them
Moana despite there being many character
alterations most of them aren't that big
of a deal in fact the average person
barely even notices them besides it's
usually secondary characters who get
swapped out or altered but that's not
the case with Moana in Spain Moana is a
brand so they changed her name and the
title of the movie to Vienna which
translates to water Cave Italy had a
slightly bigger problem with Moana there
was a famous actress named Moana Posey
but she didn't star in anything remotely
family-friendly if you know what we mean
Disney changed the name of the movie to
Oceania in Italy they just didn't want
an inappropriate image which of these
character changes shocked you the most
let us know in the comments thanks for
watching make sure to subscribe to the
things for more videos like this one and
before you go don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up we'll see you next
time
[Music]